nick pavetta on the bump after the win
last night
in game two of this series against the
orioles so cedric is out at second base
nobody down and in steps ryan mout
castle
breaking ball hammered and it's a
two-nothing oriole lead wow ryan mount
castle jumped on that pitch
the birds go on top and ryan montcastle
has just become a member of the 30 home
run club first oriole rookie to ever do
that he was pretty excited to pass cal
ripken and get to 29. no doubt about
that one jim well that was a bullet so
we got a double it almost looks like
this is a cutter no it's curveball you
know ryan was down on the field the
other day he's like you know i love the
curveball from the lefty well i think he
loves it from a right-hander he blasts
that one over the green monster and zach
lowther first time he's had a chance to
pitch at fenway park coming off not
particularly good performance couple
home runs early in the game against
toronto because they do that against
everybody brings up rafael devers and in
scoring position for devers here in the
first
there's a ground ball left side under
the diving martin in the left field it
goes and kiki's rounding 30 will score
raffy drives in
run number 104
and it's two to one red sucks have cut
the lead in half just like that if rappy
gets
the rbi martin went diving to his right
he didn't have great range and going
under his body well what happened to
help the red sox is that he deflected it
just enough so it sort of diverted it
towards center field not an easy play by
any means you see the dive ball sort of
beat him you know just beat him rbi base
hit here by devers and they do answer
right away somewhat similar to last
night when the orioles homered in the
second the red sox came right back with
two in the home half of that second
inning bobby dalbeck as hot as can be
louder deals
and dalbeck
[Applause]
2-0 you know licking his chops almost
went bridge almost went bridge we'll
take the double though looked like a
change up 2-0 change-up right down the
middle got the end of the bat if that
was a fastball that would have been
bridge but got enough of it here in
fenway park and the rbi machine is just
keeps on track and doesn't he that is
unbelievable what he's been doing it's
not a cliche he is a different guy here
is austin wins austin's hit safely in
six of his last nine games
and that's hammered way back
and austin wins got himself a long ball
out of the ballpark
left the building i believe yeah
turnpike is
that didn't get to the turn bike it's
headed in the right direction though
home run number four for austin and
we're tied at three
all i know is you got cora moving around
you got you know dave bush moving around
and the orioles tie the ball game up so
get the hitting shoes on oh high heater
hitters count and yep abetted i mean he
doesn't even follow it i always try to
watch him and see how far they go
he doesn't even look he just whiplash
somewhere
by the citgo side he's trying to make
deppers field this bunt is what he's
trying to do on a 1-2 a fastball's hit
to second iglesias flips bogarts all day
to throw and get two how about this game
two weak hits to get runners on first
and second and then a guy stings it a
little bit and it's a double play ball
so easy had all day to turn this thing
bogey look back at third watch this
he'll look back at third like
you got that much time to look back to
third but that ball was the hardest hit
ball obviously of the inning and you get
two out of it
and that's gonna end the day for nick
pavetta can bring in darwin zinn
hernandez against the lefty mullins who
had a couple of hits off pavetta who
exits in the fourth mullins 288 on the
season with nine home runs off lefties
and he goes the opposite way at
schwarber and hernandez comes on in two
pitches and does his job brings up
zander after the devers double one out
two two
and bogart slaces this one into left
center field and that'll give the red
sox the lead
zander comes through yeah he gave him a
pitch to hit he didn't miss it that
slider was very hittable and he stayed
right on it he just did it hit a seed to
center field once again slider doesn't
do anything sitting there right for him
got the barrel to it line drive base hit
center field
takes the lead finally through four to
three you've been waiting for this for a
few innings one of the red sox gonna
take the lead and they did i mean he is
locked in everything right on the button
so kk hits the wall for the second time
here's hunter renfro who is grounded out
to short struck out did a fly ball to
right
hits this one hard to center with
mullins on the move and out of his reach
clangs off the wall as kiki scores from
first
and hunter renfro adds to the lead
you can't hit it much harder and much
farther and not hit a ball out of the
ballpark except in fenway park and
mullins had a beat on it and he had a
long ways to go cross seam fastball he
threw it behind before not this time got
the barrel to it he crushes this ball
this ball is gone
in a lot of ballparks
and he's saying not here you got to get
on your horse look at this ball just out
of the reach of mullins about 410 feet
away easily can't reach far enough for
it double rbi waiting for that knockout
blow
last night it was the whole double by
renfro right that cleared the bases
bogey has looked really good so far
bogarts destroys this one
there's the knockout blow
knocked me out i told you and this is
just waiting he was perched
waiting to go bridge you knew it was
coming you just knew it was coming there
it is what a day by
bogey hit the ball hard every time up
and he loses three-run johnsons are a
beautiful thing look at that look at
that that is so pretty you could look at
it and everything get out of here hi
fastball are you kidding me no way this
ball is cleaned out and now the infield
comes in for christian vasquez who rolls
it towards second schwarber scores
on a double play well the base running
by schwarmer pays off he scores on this
two gone so here's ryan mout castle the
o2 pitch
he got him swinging four in a row for
the red sox
9-3 the final the bullpen is nails once
again sander bogarts with the three run
homer and four rbis as the red sox go to
85 and 65 with their
win today over these baltimore orioles
they are now 11 and 4 in the season
series